our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we are getting highlighting to
community leaders who set out to improve
their neighborhood by simply cleaning it
up DeMarco Morgan went to Gloucester
Township in New Jersey to meet Shirley
Johnson and Carolyn grace and the
younger residents they're both inspiring
community organizers Shirley Johnson and
Carolyn grace are leading a group of
mostly kid volunteers for second annual
clean-up day in their southern New
Jersey community it's a good it's a
community that needs people to care
about it and I think they just wanted a
couple of people who lead them in the
right direction with trash bags rakes
had a bit of spray paint they are out to
change the image of the neighborhood one
where nearly 10% of its 388 homes were
abandoned just three years ago this
particular development really was one of
the shining stars in Gloucester Township
in its heyday David Maher is the town's
mayor but through the 80s what happened
was a lot of absentee landlords came in
and bought property here so the the
neighborhood kind of went through a
decline 10 years were fine and then all
of a sudden overnight it was this away
and January a resident died after a
13-hour armed standoff with police
investigators say the man fired shots at
officers why did you choose to stay I
have roots here just because something
goes bad you don't pack up and leave
that's my opinion
more determined that discouraged Johnson
and grace launched their community
organization two and a half years ago in
the beginning Shirley and I were the
ones going around picking up and
cleaning up people's yards
since then roads have been paved on home
improvements have taken off at the new
park is now in place if you see our
letters Brittany woods Community Action
Group that a means a lot.the a is about
action the kids we met agree 100%
miss Shirley and miss Carolyn are they
cool people they do a lot of things if
you're in mr. Lee's neighborhood and
you'd throw something on the floor she
will not like oh she doesn't play to us
no she didn't
getting things done also takes
cooperation with local government guys
he's on speed Public Works is on speed
though it's really a Civic re-engagement
civics 101 actually I believe in local
governments so much because that's where
the rubber meets the road and that's
where we have to solve problems I don't
know what they're doing in Washington
but we're solving problems here locally
and proving police relations has also
been a top priority of the past decade
the day after that shooting in January
officers arrived with his command unit
turned arcade an effort to reinforce
their commitment to the kids here one of
the things that I noticed was a police
officer playing football with some of
the kids out here it's a beautiful sight
mm-hmm so as a part of our overall
community policing strategy here in
Gloucester Township and and I will tell
you it's working but young people know
that they can walk up to a police
officer and they can say hello
that the police officers are there to
help them from above you can see
Brittany woods is part of a much broader
community one that includes more
affluent neighborhoods just over the
fence they have to see this community
a healthy community not a community they
shouldn't come into it's a community
where we're all together so just because
you're on the other side of the fence
doesn't mean that we're not all together
and as for those abandoned homes from a
few years ago 35 plus abandoned homes
now down to two Joe a reminder that big
changes often come from the most humble
of efforts for CBS this morning the
barco Mortgage Gloucester Township New
Jersey I love that image of the police
officers playing football yes that's an
amazing turnaround there yeah that's
really great so we can happen in other
towns as well